many of these young footballers in
sevastopol hope to become professionals
one day until recently their club played
in Ukraine's Premier League but now the
boys dreams have been dashed at least
for now now following the Russian
annexation of Crimea in March the club
should technically also belong to Russia
the boys are confused we don't have a
professional team anymore now they're
trying to set up a new one of course
we're worried and now our sports school
is also under threat but does this man
yeah this is my life football means
everything to me I've devoted almost all
my life to it still bug none of them
ever imagined they could ever become
political pawns but the club
psychologist says the current crisis is
a recurring topic in the dressing room
mr. garrison he is business woman of
course we're all concerned but
especially the young players they're not
mature enough to have fixed views about
politics or citizenship what's important
is that they don't lose their love of
sport that they remain physically fit
and don't forget everything they've
learned yeah we of course which any
database it out now they can only attend
training sessions the authorities have
forbidden them from playing in the
Ukrainian league and the Ukrainian
Football Association refuses to let them
transfer to the Russian league a vexing
situation for club founder yevgeni
repent cough he says the club's
professional players have already left
and now play for other Ukrainian teams
while these young players are left out
in the cold well you better would they
give you all these boys on the field
have been registered in the Ukrainian
football association since they were 10
and now it's not letting them play for
Russia yet open yet I can't understand
that we think that would go idiot if you
follow you follow about feet on UEFA
aren't they supposed to defend the
interests of football players that you
could either show different idiot the
team wants to kick off the new season in
Sevastopol biggest stadium as a new
Russian club even without the go-ahead
from international football associations
if permission were granted it could be
seen by Moscow as a sign of approval for
Russia's annexation of the Crimean
Peninsula the Russian football
authorities readily issued the club with
a new license and also provided 15 new
Russian players but there isn't enough
money the club's former sponsor withdrew
his support because he disagreed with
Russia's annexation and the banking
system has collapsed listen well I've
been in Moscow several times and I've
met many football organizations and
politicians the decision was taken to
support the club because now even I
can't take a loan out as a businessman
let alone a club the banks aren't
working but the young players don't want
to wait until normality returns they
want to play and they want politics to
be kept out of football repent cough has
called on the Ukrainian Football
Association to set them free so that
Sevastopol can play again even if it
means under the Russian flag a view of
total I want to believe that our boys
will be able to play again football is
for people for the fans for the people
of the city I believe that FIFA and UEFA
will come to us and say yes you're right
football is a national sport I believe
our club will blossom and will attract
even more boys would somewhat use equip
it illegal for years it didn't matter in
Crimea who was Russian and who was
Ukrainian
that's why many of the boys wouldn't
mind playing for a Russian team in your
room see we're training again and we're
hoping that everything will be great
again that's though the most nubile as
we get into the Russian league it will
all be fine what I see Scotty get them
whatever the level is higher in the
Russian league and so is the training
I've heard it's better than in Ukraine
then what's a jungle clean they say they
can prove themselves in the Russian
league if only they're allowed to play
yevgeni repent cough has some 500
talented young men in his club he can't
send them all home